this video is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them in the
middle of the video hello everyone I'm
Alana welcome to my Channel today we're
recording another q a
um clearly I'm not at home which is why
this is happening
I look like Cortana
it's very blue this is a q a that
focuses on video games and all things
video game adjacent I do q and A's for
all other topics on my second Channel
which I will leave Linked In the
description below and if you want to ask
questions for next time you would leave
them in the comments of this video I
generally do a new q a on like the 14th
or 15th of every month next version is
from cool soccer and it says
I actually think I'm gonna move this one
to the start of the video so
um just because there's a lot of
comments about it right now it says Hey
Alana just wondering if you had seen
what Caden had to say on Twitter I know
you guys worked together at Rooster
Teeth and I was wondering if you had
anything to comment
um so for anyone who missed this I'm
happy to talk about it in support of Ken
speaking up finally about a lot of stuff
that I know bothered Kaden for a long
time but I also know that a lot of my
audience maybe doesn't uh know who Kaden
is or know uh much about Rooster Teeth
in general which is what this post is
about so basically uh somebody named
Matt got laid off or let go recently and
I know that Roost teeth are um going
through a lot of layoffs right now and
restructuring right now which I find to
be very unsurprising I feel like I knew
that even when I was working there that
that was coming but regardless it still
really sucks and they've laid off a lot
of very good people I think some of them
aren't even public yet
and instead of changing the workload
they've just made the remaining people
have to take on those workloads and work
harder so like layoffs but the people
who've stayed just have to pick up that
work and layoffs of like really
important structural roles it seems like
they are keeping people who have
followers and laying off people
regardless of how good they are at their
jobs or how important they are or what
they do and how important what they do
is for the talent it doesn't matter if
you don't have followers of you on on
camera they're just kind of laying you
off
at least that's my perspective I do not
work there currently um
I don't want to pretend to have the most
informed perspective so I think Matt
being laid off and talking about how
much that sucked um and he definitely
got a lot of Community Support prompted
Kaden who also worked at rooster teeth
from uh 2013 to 2020 I believe to come
forward about some of her experiences
working there
including that she had a nickname
um when she originally worked at
Achievement Hunter that was I don't even
know how to best say this the F slur
it's a homophobic slur that she was just
calls that it was like a nickname but
then on camera they would call her thugs
as a way to get around saying that word
which I remember the day that she told
me that it would have been in 2020 I
think maybe a week before I left the
company I had no idea that was the thing
that was happening and I was so shocked
um I still don't have any other reaction
other than just pure shock uh hearing
that that was a thing that that happened
to her when she was first at the company
but I never really asked for more detail
and I never asked for who said it I just
offered support obviously and and
listened that's pretty much it a lot of
the rest of her post is about how she
was underpaid and promised things that
she wasn't given and that all happened
at Rooster Teeth in Austin and um I have
no doubt that everything that she said
regarding all of that is completely true
but again I cannot actually speak to it
I didn't work there so then Mika button
who also worked at Rusty for a while
um reiterated something that she said in
the past and said that she's read really
poorly and I don't feel like I've ever
been shy about this I've said so like
multiple times repeatedly maybe just
like I've never publicly Associated the
two but it's a very easy to do I think I
repeatedly said that 2018 was the worst
year of my life so bad and it was
because of working conditions at Rooster
Teeth I fell apart it was terrible I've
spoken about this publicly I made a
video on this channel about it about how
I literally developed eczema a skin
condition that I now deal with all the
time because I was so
stressed out and frazzled and
um just like overwhelmed and like in a
terrible place
that I I developed a skin condition and
when I went to a doctor about it and I
was like my hands keep burning
um obviously I got diagnosed by a
dermatologist he was like yeah this is
eczema and in your situation it sounds
like it's been caused by stress and now
every time I'm stressed I get eczema
like this is basically the amount of
stress that I was under
caused me a theoretically permanent skin
condition which is just like nuts
unbelievable and that's not to say that
any of the stuff that I went through was
worse than
um or even comparable to what Kaden and
Mika dealt with it's just to illustrate
a point of like not a little bit
stressed like stressed enough that I had
a physical reaction because my body was
like listen [ __ ] this is not good and
so I left the company
um that year or in 2019 I don't remember
I think I left in 2019 but I left as
soon as I could
um but I went to contract work so that I
could still make some content but that I
didn't have to
be a part of the company culture of
Rooster Teeth in the same way
because I couldn't do it anymore my
health was a goddamn mess I mean I'll
say things at fun house specifically are
really really great right now like the
the energy there is wonderful and
positive and all of the people who work
there full-time are really wonderful
supportive people it almost feels from
my perspective like fun houses like the
bright spot of Rooster Teeth where
everybody's like very currently Happy
from what I'm aware of for the most part
I imagine they're still annoyed with
receipt management I'm not actually sure
but I still go in and make videos when I
can obviously outside of work because
I'm happy to be there and happy to work
with those people but Rosita is the
worst place that I've ever worked and
yeah I think some of that is on me and
that I dealt with it poorly because I
just didn't
I didn't
um know how to respond to a shitty
situation it
talk about geek
Y and when they originally asked to
partner with me as part of my YouTube
videos I reached out to a bunch of
friends who I knew used keeps they all
really heavily encouraged they offer
clinically proven treatments to combat
the symptoms of hair loss because there
is no magic cure for baldness but you
can prevent hair loss from happening in
the first place first you get the FDA
approved provider recommended plan
that's right for you without ever
leaving your couch with keeps you can
get quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or Pharmacy
step two is of course sitting back and
waiting for your daily supply of
treatment to arrive every three months
at half the cost of a pharmacy all keeps
treatments plans are doctor recommended
and delivered straight to your door and
then part three is take action track
progress and get support along the way
with keeps this network of Expert
Medical advisors prescribers and Care
Specialists to support you in making
your hair loss goals a reality whether
you're looking to prevent a hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair you have keeps
has you covered in addition to its
clinically proven treatments keeps has
an award-winning all-natural thickening
shampoo and conditioner system and the
keeps Physicians will help you select
the right products and treatments for
your specific condition and hair goals
so it's time to take action hair loss
stops with keeps to get 50 off your
first order go to keeps.com online
appears or click the link in the
description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Alana Pierce
definitely the worst job I've ever had
some of the stuff that um I know that HR
did to myself and to other people while
I was working there was like
unbelievably horrific and I think that
probably the problem with the rooster
teeth company culture is you hire a lot
of creatives who want to do cool
creative [ __ ] and they think that they
can
and they're excited too and then
everything pivots every six months so
every the goal posts are always moving
all of the time the company has this
real problem with promising people
things and then not delivering on any of
them which is obviously going to create
really low morale for your stuff but
yeah I mean I could go on for ages uh I
don't feel but I want to I will just say
I 100 support Kaden and Mika in
everything that they've said I know what
Caden said is true
um and Rooster Teeth was a really shitty
place to work even if I keep thinking
some of that self-inflicted because I
didn't deal with the shitty circumstance
very well
but yeah I left Rooster Teeth because I
couldn't [ __ ] work there anymore like
that's why I left and then when I was
still working as a contractor I was
happier because I was very removed but
they still did [ __ ] like even when I was
a contractor they had a women in games
panel
um that because I was a contractor they
just couldn't have me on because they
didn't want to pay me
now you're gonna have a women in games
panel and be like
hey Alana
um know that you're currently working on
a gaming brand for us two gaming brands
at the time it was fun house and inside
gaming it's time but uh we'd prefer not
to pay you to do this panel so which is
the same as like what Kaden said about
not getting paid to do vo generally I
don't think anyone except for maybe the
cast of gen lock got paid to do any of
that stuff I used to do that's why they
call you a content creator that was my
actual job title at roosted which is
insane because of what I was was a
writer producer but they call you
content creator when you work there so
that you can do anything so that your
job titles are literally all types of
production so that they don't have to
adjust what they pay you because content
creator means that all Duties are
technically your job so yeah I don't
know what else to say
um I'll leave a link to both Matt and
Kaden's statements below and I sure hope
that Rooster Teeth gets better
um but I think it is probably more
likely that it will dissolve and I do
think it's been heading in that
direction for a pretty long time and
there are a lot of people who work there
that I really really really like that I
really
hope go on to do better things first
question is from LL Cool tj9 which I'm
assuming is related to recent news that
God of War Ragnarok has gone gold the
question says Alana can you define what
it means in a digital age for a
game-going gold so we announced last
week the week before that God of War
Ragnarok has gone gold the digital Age
part is an interesting question because
it's kind of not relevant gone gold
basically means that the game is ready
to be put on discs it is a weird phrase
I don't know where it comes from because
gone gold like in other Industries tends
to uh relate to sales probably a silly
phrase to be honest
Matthew Evan said what do you think
about the surge of battle passes seems
like every multiplayer game offers them
now do you invest or pass them up given
your position on paying beyond the
initial cost of the game I have never
bought a battle pass ever
and I will never buy a battle pass ever
it's not something that I
um am like a part of a community in
video games that like I feel the need to
yell at anybody because I know that
won't change anything
don't do microtransactions or battle
passes
or loot boxes or any of it and uh
I realize I'm so out of focus that's a
shame WV said so now that you've
achieved becoming a Dev is there another
goal career-wise for the next year or
several years are you just cruising for
the time being and learning as much as
you can do you want to work your way up
the career ladder do you see yourself
going back to journalism I'm definitely
never going to go back to journalism
there's no way
um I'm very happy working at Santa
Monica Studio I can't see myself leaving
anytime soon I have no interest in
going up the career ladder I don't want
to be a manager I've done it before and
it's not fun I just want to write and
you only get to do that if you stay a
writer
I did just get promoted though I am no
longer a junior writer I am now just a
writer a mid-level writer so that's cool
the work that I do is not that of a
junior item
um
really have any other career goals right
now there are things that I want to do
outside of work that I hope to do more
once Ragnarok ships I intended to make
uh one short film a year but that just
didn't happen this year hopefully I can
pick that back up and do more of that
and
start working on more other cool stuff
like I've got an offer to work on a
comic that I would have loved to have
done but just didn't think I had the
time or mental energy I want to do more
of that kind of stuff so stuff outside
of work but work wise very happy where I
am no interested in
climbing any career ladders just want to
write which is all I've really ever
wanted to do
I know when I was hired at IGN as a
writer which is what I was hired to do
and they kept wanting to put me on
camera for [ __ ] that ended up being like
this struggle of departments where I had
to be like hey
you're making me do all the riding work
and all the camera work and it's too
[ __ ] much it's nice to finally work
at a company who has no interest in me
being on camera like Sony could not be
less interested in having me represent
the brand and it's very nice I just get
to write which is all I've ever wanted
to do Guitar Hero Aero said I have a
degree in computer science and gaming is
my passion working in the games industry
would a would be a dream naturally I'm
drawn toward companies that have made
games that I love but something that
holds me back as I feel I might ruin my
ability to experience games from my
favorite franchises for the first time
if I'm directly involved in their
creation and working behind the curtain
especially from the standpoint of
getting to experience the narrative with
that in mind is there anything you feel
you've lost or otherwise can relate to
that feeling in any way through working
at Santa Monica Studio so this is also a
really common question
um and my answer is no I don't feel like
I've lost anything all I've done is gain
seeing how things are made when it's
something that you love is really cool
and because of the size of a studio you
get to see what other departments are
working on like in small bursts and um
it's like every week there's some really
cool reveal of something that somebody
did that's like oh that's awesome and I
think you get that experience so
frequently that it's like better than
having it all in one sitting when a game
comes out so yes it's certainly not the
same as playing the game as a consumer
at all
but I think it's better personally all
right I think I will leave it there it's
hard to want to talk about anything else
after the rooster teeth stuff to be
honest add a lot of the questions are
just very similar at this point that is
it for me today sorry that I've been
blurry this whole time I will see you
guys next time bye